Goals in this inverted pyramid
of sort of a hierarchy.
Hi, there Steve Kaufmann here today
and I'm going to talk today about
goals, goals in language learning.
Uh, remember if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe.
Um, Click on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast service,
which I think is a good thing to do,
because then you can listen, especially
if you're using my videos to improve
your English, you can listen to them
while you're in the car or whatever
you're doing, but to do leave a review.
I do appreciate it.
So why do I want to talk about goals?
Uh, um, personally, I have the sort
of general interest in learning
languages which motivates me.
So I don't really focus on any
particular goals, but I, I sort of
gave the subject some thought, you
know, so much of the time when we're
learning a language, we have the
feeling that we're not progressing.
We're not getting anywhere.
And so I thought it, it, it is useful.
I kind of looked at what I do
and, and what are the goals that
I focus on at different stages?
In my language learning, what are,
what sort of is the hierarchy of goals?
And so that's what I want
to talk about a bit today.
At least my hierarchy of goals, uh,
what I kind of consider to be more
important at what stage in my learning.
Uh, and, uh, there are seven of
them and I'm gonna talk about the
seven a day, and then I've been
giving some thought to doing one uh
video on each of these seven goals.
In other words, how do we,
you know, achieve those goals?
How do we use those goals to
improve our, our, uh, ability in
the language that we're learning?
So, first of all, I see these seven
goals as sort of an inverted pyramid,
uh, where the first one, which I
will start to discuss shortly is
at the top as a broad sort of line.
Uh, and then the next one comes below it.
And so they get sort of narrower
and yet they're expanding sort of
horizontally, uh, all the time.
Uh, so let me tell you what I mean.
So the first goal in language learning
uh, the one that's easiest to sort
of measure and which stays with you
all the time is acquiring words.
All right.
That's why we have at LingQ, we measure
the words you know, uh, we also measure
phrases or we at least let you save
phrases, but the key measurement is
the words you know, and, um, certainly
that's what I focus on at the beginning.
Uh, and I will get into detail
when I do my video on words.
But that's kind of like the initial,
I often refer to the mechanical rabbit
that you're chasing this thing to try
and, you know, you're running this
race and you're pursuing the rabbit.
To me the mechanical rabbit is words.
That's the number one goal.
And when you start in the language,
that's what you're trying to do.
You're...
one word at a time you're
learning how this language works.
So number one goal is
words, acquiring words.
The second goal on this inverted
pyramid, one level down is
reading, reading comprehension.
It's a lot easier to understand
what you read than to understand
what you're listening to.
So as you are acquiring words, uh,
you're also developing the ability
to make sense of what you read, not a
hundred percent, but you're starting
to make sense of what you read.
If you're using LingQ, you're looking
words up, you're adding these words
to your known words total, or to
your words that you have looked
up that are in your database.
So the next sort of goal is to increase
the number of words that you are reading,
something that we also measure at LingQ.
Then the third goal is
listening comprehension.
Uh, it it's, I find it
difficult to understand what I
listen to if I don't read it.
So that's why in my hierarchy of
goals, I start with acquiring words
and I wanna see that number go up:
LingQs created, you know, known words
uh, reading, number of words read.
I wanna see that go up, but
at the same time, I wanna work
on my listening comprehension.
Now to some extent, the listening
comprehension, the learning words, the
reading is all happening at the same time.
But in terms of a goal that
I set for myself initially, I
want that word count to go up.
Second of all, I wanna read more
words and I'll get into more detail
when I do a video on reading.
The third thing is to improve
my listening comprehension.
So those are the first three goals,
the next goal then, and you'll, you'll
sort of realize now that, because I
always talk about input, acquiring
words, reading, listening, those are
the top three then comes speaking.
So, uh, as a goal, you know, ultimately at
the end, of course, I wanna able to speak
well, but initially, that's not my goal.
Initially my goal is comprehension:
words, reading comprehension,
listening comprehension.
And if I have those, a good base in
those, the speaking will be easier for me.
Then of course I wanna speak as much as
I can, but if I have that solid base in
the earlier goals, the words, the reading
comprehension, listening comprehension,
then the speaking is gonna come.
Now, after speaking comes grammar
or usage or speaking correctly.
So in other words, I don't worry
at all about how correctly I speak
at an early stage in the language.
My goals initially are input related.
Then I'm speaking, speaking with mistakes.
It doesn't matter.
Then comes a point where I want to
focus in on speaking more correctly.
And this comes after struggling to
speak and throwing out the words
and the phrases that I've acquired.
And now I want to work towards
speaking more correctly.
And when I do my video on how to learn
grammar, I will talk in more detail
about how we learn grammar and speak more
correctly or more like native speakers.
So the goals so far have been first goal,
biggest goal, which stays with us, all
of these, stay with us the whole time:
acquiring words.
Reading second goal:
reading comprehension.
Third is listening comprehension.
Fourth is speaking.
Fifth is, uh, grammar learning to,
uh, use the language more correctly.
Then the sixth one is writing.
And again, we can start writing
at any time, but, and I, I
just look at my own experience.
I tend not to write a lot, except when
I was in a situation where I needed
to write when I was learning Chinese.
I was on a program.
I was working for the Canadian government.
I had to learn to read, excuse me,
to write and to write correctly.
Similarly, when I was a student in
France, I had, I had to write correctly.
So there are many situations where
we need to write and write correctly.
And I will do a video on how we improve
our ability to write and to write uh, you
know, effectively and, uh, persuasively
and accurately and all these things.
So that then is the sixth goal is the
writing goal, at least in my hierarchy.
And the final goal is the culture.
And, uh, I think at least in my
learning, when I learn a language,
I learn the language in order
to connect with the culture.
However, as a goal, It's further down
the list because until I have the reading
comprehension, the listing comprehension,
the words, um, you know, a better sense
of the language, it's difficult to
get into the details of the culture.
So again, like so many of these goals, we
can introduce them at any time, but I find
that I'm much more interested in things
that relate to the grammar of the lang...
or excuse me, that relate to
the, uh,  to the culture of
the language that I'm learning.
If I have a better ability to read about
these things comfortably in the language,
rather than having different aspects of
the culture, uh, festivals or different
family relationships, having all of this
explained to me, say in English, uh,
at a point where I don't have a good
understanding of the language, I prefer
to save that until I can go out and
discover it for myself in the language.
And so I will do another video
specifically on this seventh goal.
So all I wanted to do today was to
sort of warn you, let you know that
I'm going to be doing these seven
videos on the seven goals uh, in
so far as my learning is concerned.
Which are these, uh, goals
in this inverted pyramid of
sort of a hierarchy of goals.
The top one is, uh, words, get
getting as many words as you can.
The second one is developing
your, uh, reading comprehension.
The second one.
The third one is developing
your listing comprehension.
The fourth one is speaking.
Uh, the fifth one is working
on your correct usage.
The sixth one is writing and the
seventh and final one is really
gaining an appreciation of the culture.
So there you have it.
Of course, there's a lot of overlap
and many of these things, it can
be happening at different stages,
but that is my hierarchy of goals.
So I hope that was used useful.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.